Nó ngay mùi chiến thằng chiến năm 2018, tại Sá Anh Sơn, nghĩa an, mùi người danh ông không mấy bị đàn ông bình công, giấn đến tử vòng.
Thế đó, sang cùng ngay ông phản phân nở, sinh năm 2018, chú thôn Kinh Nhanh một Sá Anh Sơn chào tuyên gia mẹ sông làm cách nhà khoảng 2 kêu mết để cất khỏe cho đàn cả nguy.
Đến hình chưa, không thể ông chờ về vừa ông lo lắng đi tìm.
Tại bơn sông, bà phát hiện trước khiến của chúng vẫn nhau đậu như khó thể người.
Thì đi giọc mở sông, bà bà khoảng phát hiện ông nở năm bất đậu gần 1 tuo ám, trên người có nhiều vết đốt.
Nghe lực tức, bà đá hồ hãng bà con trong thương đến ứng kêu, gọi xe đưa đi chúng tôi bị tìa anh sơn cấp vữ.
Tuy nhiên, giờ bị ông đối quá nhiều, đã nhên đã khu quả khó.
Được biết, ra đi ngốc nở thuộc dựng cận nèo, sau sự việc bị bán như sản xương đã đến thăm họ, chia mùn và hỗ trợ ra điện nạn nhân ba chự đồng.
Chính quyền xã anh sơn, quyền cáo, người dân cần cần trong khi đi lào đậu nhất là vào buồn này, khi ông thương làm tổ ở các buổi giống về sông, về nưu dễ.
Nguyên dân nên tránh lại cần tổ ám, không nên mà còn hảo mổ sức sức hóa có mùi mỗi mối với dễ kiếc đậu đàn ám.
Chứ hợp không mấy bị ông tình công, cần nhé trong tình cách chè mà phát hiện ngay cơ sởi tế để được sử liy ký thời.